22 years ago i opened this baby at
restaurant gordon ramsay back in 1998.
uh what a journey uh over two decades of
absolute utter perfection
and you know what um i bought the
restaurant off an amazing frenchman
called pierre kaufman
and i sold my flats and i conjured up
the money to buy this but
i was short and you know what he did he
told me to pay
some now and the rest in a year's time
after the success of the first year's
trading and that
was generous beyond belief since then
two
decades later we're still here 19 years
this year as a three-star michelin and
honestly it feels like
22 weeks because striving for that level
of perfection
is hard but this may be the name above
the door
but the real talent is inside let me
introduce you
let's go
so we're celebrating 22 years so we get
a chance to let the customers know
22 years yeah and when everyone says
what were you doing 22 years ago yeah i
was
in the [ __ ] with john claude
mcdormany
oh man first of all happy birthday 22
years
today 22 years um you've been here now
just coming up 12 years
took over the reigns literally five
years ago
i'm so happy that you're the chef patron
thank you very much
what's the difference by standing that
side to run this side
how do you in your mind cope with not
just the pressure
and that level of insight but
how do you separate that difference the
biggest difference for me now standing
this side of the past instead of in the
kitchen
uh is allowing myself to orchestrate the
service watch over the guys and to make
sure
that everything's coming together
properly how do you think you've changed
in the last 10 years
how about changing the last 10 years
well there's been a lot of change
i've grown as a chef my palette's
developed i've grown with confidence
you know i've grown in my managerial
skills and my leadership and
leading the team roles world has always
been
instrumental with clean flavours
literally closing your eyes and
identifying
you know what you're eating not
overworked over fussed
but what's been the what's been the
highlight of those ingredients in your
mind
you know whether it's the lamb the beef
the turbo but
what what stands out so my standout
product would have to be the herdwick
lamb
from the lake district got an amazing
balance of meat to fat ratio the flavour
is stunning and it's an absolute
pleasure to cook every day
22 years in the making um i'm one of the
fish the meat today where we going
you're underneath
on the meat please don't shout at me
you